ja und wir sprechen jetzt in berlin mit
dem konzern sprecher der deutschen bahn
nach ihm staus ich grüße sie sie gehen
jetzt juristisch in die zweite instanz
rechnen sie sich der bessere chancen aus
schwer zu beurteilen im ersten durchgang
hat es nicht geklappt aber ich glaube
dass wir unseren fahrgästen auch
schuldig in einer solchen situation wo
so ein unsäglich langer streik läuft
alles zu versuchen auch juristische
schritte auszuloten um diesen unnötigen
streit zu beenden nun sagt der gdl chef
weselsky er wäre ja verhandlungsbereit
wenn alle forderungen erfüllt würden die
gdl können sie das irgendwie
nachvollziehen fürchtet ja durch das
tarif einheits gesetz und ihrer existenz
ja eine solche aussage ist natürlich ein
widerspruch in sich das klingt eher nach
tarifdiktat als nach
verhandlungsbereitschaft die gdl hat
sich nicht bewegt und zwar kein
millimeter seit ende mai wir hingegen
haben einen abschluss von 3,2 prozent
vorgeschlagen
sogar jetzt noch mal die laufzeit
verkürzt wir sind bereit zu einer gronau
prämie von 400 oder 600 euro die noch in
diesem jahr wirksam würde und das alles
vor dem hintergrund einer schweren
finanziellen krise der wir uns befinden
und einen lohnabschluss von 2,6 prozent
im vergangenen jahr also es ist wirklich
an der zeit dass auch die gdl sich
bewegt und sich auf einer dazu bewegen
das ist eben das wesen dass der
charakter von tarifverhandlungen
aber das muss man am tisch machen am
verhandlungstisch und nicht im bahnhof
bei streiks das ist ja genau die frage
die sich der bahnkunde stellt und sie
sich ja wahrscheinlich auch vom vorstand
wie kriegen wie kommen sie wieder
zusammen an einen tisch dass sie mit der
gdl wieder ins verhandeln kommen also
haben sie noch irgendwie in ass im ärmel
oder welche strategie haben sie dennoch
wir appellieren an die vernunft und das
verantwortungsbewusstsein an der
gewerkschaft die einen völlig überzogen
streit vom zaun bricht dritte schon in
folge das ist völlig unangemessen und
man kann so nicht vorwärtskommen wir
müssen am tisch verhandeln man kann über
alles sprechen wir reden ja sogar über
die gleichen 3,2 prozent wir sind bei
der laufzeit nach außen anders wir sind
der gdl ist sogar noch mit einer corona
premiere entgegen gekommen also bewegung
ist aber leider nur auf einer seite
vorhanden hier muss die gdl endlich
verantwortungsbewusstsein zeigen
und einen tisch zurückkommen ich meine
das ist jetzt alles kaffeesatzleserei
aber es gab ja 2014 14 schon mal so eine
situation die jetzt danach ist die gdl
zurückgekehrt also was was erwarten sie
denn was hoffen sie denn
das stichwort vor fünf jahren ist er
sehr gut denn wir haben das traf ein
neues gesetz ja schon einige jahre und
in den ersten jahren ist es uns ja auch
gelungen mit beiden gewerkschaften mit
der kleinen gdl und der größeren evg ein
kooperationsabkommen zu schließen so
eine friedliche koexistenz zu
ermöglichen und das hätten wir ja auch
gerne verlängert aber es gab daneben
seitens der gewerkschaften da keine
bereitschaft zu so dass wir jetzt
gezwungen sind das tarif ein als gesetz
anzuwenden
wir haben festgestellt dass in den usa
300 betrieben der deutschen war nur in
16 betrieben die gdl mit ihrer
mitglieder überhaupt eine mehrheit hat
das zeigt eben auch das missverhältnis
und die unverhältnismäßigkeit von
solchen streiks was kostet denn sonst
reicht eigentlich am tag und wie viel
hat er bisher schon gekostet
also ein streik kostet vor allem
vertrauen der fahrgäste die sich
eigentlich darauf verlassen können
müssen dass die bahn fährt wir haben
zwar einen verlässlichen ersatzfahrplan
der ist auch zuverlässig aber er ist
eben doch nur an der satz fahrplan im
fernverkehr vielleicht ein viertel der
normalen züge die fahren und es ein
schwerer schaden für die wirtschaft die
jetzt gerade nach den harten monaten der
pandemie wieder in gang kommt die
wirtschaft ist exportorientiert
sie möchte waren verladen die konjunktur
springt wieder an und auch hier ist die
gdl der hemmt diese entwicklung und das
ist eben auch verwerflich dass wir
gerade in dieser phase so viele menschen
wie der urlaub machen können reisen
wollen oder auch die wirtschaft wieder
anspringt hier eine solche bremse haben
ja sie wollen ja nun an diesem
wochenende alles auf die schiene bringen
was rollt wäre es da nicht vielleicht
sinnvoll in solchen situationen die wir
jetzt haben mit dem streik das ist ja
nicht das erste mal generell ein solches
szenario wie sie es am wochenende
vorhaben in petto zu haben
ja wir sind gut vorbereitet und haben
nun inzwischen auch leider muss man
sagen eine gewisse übung in der
bewältigung solcher streiks der
ersatzfahrplan ist stabil das ist schon
auch eine herkulesaufgabe denn immer
wieder aufzustellen das macht man nicht
mit links aber wir bieten den kunden
schon einen verlässlichen fahrplan im
fernverkehr etwa ein viertel der züge im
nahverkehr regional unterschiedlich im
durchschnitt aber auch immerhin 40
prozent es gibt ja auch lokführer die
fahren einmal die beamteten kolleginnen
und kollegen aber auch all die die gar
nicht in der gewerkschaft organisiert
sind oder in der größe und evg sind ja
ich bedanke mich bei achim stauß
konzernsprecher der deutschen bahn für
dieses gespräch nach berlin